was called the spring statement and it
wasn't really supposed to be a big
fiscal moment it was supposed to be just
an update on how the economy was doing
at the moment get the new numbers from
the office of budget responsibility but
obviously there's a lot going on right
now with ukraine and with the cost of
living crisis when you have a look at
inflation this is really the big number
we're going to be focusing on uh in this
spring statement normally it's growth
normally you look at growth and indeed
the growth numbers might well be uh cut
a little bit
but this was what was forecast last time
around in 2022. four percent were
already well above that so that bar's
going to go up a lot and when you see in
terms of what it means for all of us
what it means for our pockets well
energy prices have gone up
extraordinarily and they are going to go
up even further but also there's this
look at fuel prices this is pisces at
the pump whether for diesel or for
unleaded just have a look last few years
and now look at what's happened more
recently up to record levels and in many
other countries around europe they have
cut taxes uh on petrol on fuel will the
chancellor do the same as well it would
make a big difference for many motorists
but there's another issue as well
there's the costs that he is increasing
for families this is the impact by
different income group of the health and
social care levy remember it that's
coming in this year so april
and the blue bit is how much it digs
into our incomes by income group from
the poorest through to the richest
that's the blue bit and then on top of
that you've got income tax so a change
in income tax thresholds mean more
people end up paying more income tax and
it's a lot you know you're talking about
more than a thousand pounds for the
richest and a d for the poorest there is
a big question mark given how much they
are have to pay having to pay for that
cost of living crisis about how much
they can bear so does the chancellor do
something to ameliorate this we will
have to see and finally there's a
question which isn't just about the cost
of living crisis it's about the nature
of governments it's about what we spend
our money on and have a look at this
this shows you government spending on
different functions going all the way
back to the post-war period
what i want you to focus on here is this
red slice that's defense the blue slices
health and just have a look at over time
as the decades go on from the 70s to the
80s to the 90s to the 2000s that red
slice gets thinner and thinner and
thinner the blue slice gets bigger and
that raises another question doesn't it
does the chancellor focus on getting
that up getting defense spending up
getting that red slice bigger we're
living potentially in a new world with
what's happening in russia in the
ukraine and also around the world
elsewhere
how's that going to be reflected in this
spring statement